what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news you probably
already know that Google Docs is a great
place to collaborate but and how you can
use the flexibility of an API to do even
more
whether it's importing Doc's from a
content management system or
programmatically adding and template
izing existing Doc's find the demos and
code samples that you need to get
started and see examples of it in action
at the docs API website what will you
build Google boasts a high quality
private global network that you can use
to keep your cloud applications running
smoothly
with the launch of Google clouds network
service tiers you can now optimize your
workloads for performance and cost are
you running a job where every
millisecond counts use the premium tier
to minimize the number of hops but if
you're running a more cost sensitive
workload or you're not as concerned with
network speed save some cash by using
the standard tier start customizing your
projects and workloads by choosing your
network tiers today of course if you
want to learn more about networking and
show off your skills Google has just
rolled out a new certification cloud
network engineer check out this great
blog post from a Solutions Architect who
made the leap from networking on-prem to
the cloud tom shares tips on how to stay
highly sought after in an ever-changing
landscape so study up and get certified
if you're one of the millions who
already uses box get ready to see what
happens when you take advantage of the
new Google ml services integration
upload a batch of files and watch Google
ml do all the sorting and tagging for
you want to see it for yourself follow
the code tutorial we've linked to and
have a fully functioning box integration
running in minutes
do you or someone you know have to deal
with customers if so you may know how
important customer lifetime value is and
the challenges of trying to predict it
we've got a great solutions article that
explains how to model this value with
machine learning and walks you through
how to implement and host it get your
hands on it and try it out for yourself
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud